we actually came to this topic
that our main topic is
professor franke a question is we talked
about collective guilt or the idea of collective guilt wheth
r it exists is up for debat
anyway there was something and is there
something more notice that certain react
ons  there was a collective
suppression of this guilt do you think
that now is the time
and that this series can contribute to
this suppression yes but i
have to say paradoxically
only because we are energetically
against the concept of collective
guilt waves as cruiser i was  so far 25
times in america and every time i
hold courses there at universities for a whole
semester or a quarter
after the students come to me who
know the book you were talking about
and say mr franke do
n't just tell us about your experiences in the
psychotherapy but in the last
lecture please say  Tell us something about
your experiences in concentration camps
and I'm already composed and
I always have a box with a few diaz of
the positive ones with me,
and I took them in the
former Auschwitz concentration camp
where not even many years ago with
the American  visiting professors had to
go there to show them and
to be able to do different things and i will show
them, for example, the half-bombed
gas chambers i will show you the ramp from
the train station where the first
selection took place and i
had to march up doctor mengele and he  pointing the finger to the
right or left as well as to be or
not to be, ten percent of our transport went
to the right and
then i will show you the advice so
the former picture just as well know the
former horse stables in each such stable
we have 100,000 100 people
celebrated inside
and after i showed you all the busses
slides  the last thing i will show you is
basically a photo that shows a
farm casually located in the middle
between bad wörishofen and türkheim in
türkheim was the last camp from which
i liberated troops from texas and in front of
this farm are a couple of farmers
their children's children three
generations and then  i say at the
end to these students and now
look these are the farmers who
risked their lives to hide
two jewish boys from our
concentration camp from the ss
i say
that as a matter of principle and finally give up so that the
concept of a collective guilt
will never be solved  up to
now something easy on this point as it is now
because she is a car in which the the
jewish people
is there she confronts everyone with
reality, albeit in an
artistically exaggerated sense with
reality and gives those who are not
guilty an opportunity to admit themselves
distance from the guilt un  d the
person who has become guilty also
has an opportunity
to distance himself from himself and in this way
a chance to surpass himself
in connection with
overcoming this repression,
the german psychologist speaks
mitzscherlich of the mourning work as well as or
work that is done  must to
finally really trust that's
about what the series also noticed i
personally don't believe in it because all
these concepts are much too psycho-
dynamically oriented and
see people as a bundle of certain psychological mechanisms and that's
exactly why everyone commits them at some point
it's about the human core and it
's about personal guilt or
innocence and there is a personal
guilt
i am the only jew i think
among you and maybe i have the
right or even the duty to
emphasize that there is only personal guilt
and none  collective guilt and if you
fall into the error or  the
youth work from there was already timely
and not just internally if we
let the young people believe that there is
collective guilt then
will this cause repression or do we approach
these repression tendencies
we have to tell the young people the germans
or, if you like, the
austrians in a lump sum  condemning is
exactly the same as what the nazis just did the
nazis by condemning the jews across the board
we have to
tell the people although of course
quantitative and certain style
differences are the organizational
the technological and
we still have to tell the people
that one hand  not to
imagine that it was she
who was affected by an ulcer
and not the other hand, that means that you
shouldn't imagine that
the other hand was also affected by an
ulcer and not you, it's always the
whole organism that was sick  the whole of
humanity and every single human being
personally i think
if i like the past so in the
future holocaust fink susceptible to
holocaust photo food is created in each of us
as a human possibility
or better said as
inhumanity as a possibility immense
maybe our most important topic of
all wanted but we will come back to it later
one last question about
this topic overcoming repression your colleague
ringel writes in this context how
important it is that it is just
a documentary but something
eventful it is because only the
emotional shock the deep
shock that this series has
caused is suitable  overcoming such a
barrier in people, such
repression is not
what is special about the hike now in the
entire german-speaking area, everything is in
flux, the willingness to reconsider everything, the dismay that is
talked about so much today on the part of the audience,
the  concerned can of course
only start from something concrete and
something personal but i don't want to
use the word emotionality because of
course bring in
just feeling it's more it's
something existential that it's about it
's a commitment visor president is have
indicated a commitment that for
the future direction must be device and
therefore a concern of the upbringing of his
please now bring it into the historical core of the
matter
I ask the three ins to show